it's too bad in a way that we can't
paint everything black because this map
coloring problem
sure would be a lot easier
so uh i don't know what we're going to
do about that the problem is
well how long is this going to take
maybe we should here's what i'm going to
do we're going to wait till either all
the laptops are closed or this program
terminates
whichever comes first
so how long is this going to take i
actually don't know i
i think it'll take more than a lifetime
of the universe but i'm not sure
so let's take a little bit let's take a
look at a slightly easier
map coloring problem we'll stop this one
and change the map to something i call
simplicia
there's 26 states one for each letter in
the alphabet
and what we're going to do is we're
going to do a depth first
search for a suitable coloring of this
map
we're going to go in order a b c d e and
as i've suggested here
at each level we're going to rotate the
color choices so we don't overuse any
one color
so if we launch this particular search
this depth first attempt to
color this map there it goes and maybe
we should wait until it terminates
or maybe we just let it run and
it'll terminate perhaps sometime within
the lecture or
maybe we should just let it run over the
weekend
or how long do you think we'd have to
wait if we want to come back and watch
it terminate
roughly 30 frames a second on
calculating it all in my head
i don't want to bet my life on it but i
think about 5
000 years and if you want to use
as many states as there are in the
united states
in this demonstration you get up to
numbers like
10 to the 17th years
17th 18th 16th i'm not exactly sure i
did a rough calculation
and of course you could do some
parallels into that and it's not as bad
as chess where you need all the atoms in
the universe you still can't do it and
things like that
acting as computers but still it's
pretty horrendous and the problem
the problem is well the problem is
the problem is illustrated by this
diagram i put in back of me
if you do a depth first search
and you have a a problem like
texas if you label
if you assign a color to arizona
oklahoma arkansas and louisiana
first and then wait around to do texas
last
then you get yourself into a bind
by your fourth choice that you don't
discover until your 48th choice
so what happens then is that you start
developing this tree like this
you get to those states surrounding
texas
texas is the last state assigned a color
and there's nothing left for it
and that problem was there on the fourth
choice you don't discover it until your
50th choice
so you develop a horrendous impossible
impossible search
so you simply can't do it that way
but now not to worry we now have
come equipped with the idea of
constraint propagation
so we could just take a country with
four states like this
each can be labeled red green blue and
yellow
so just like in a case of line drawings
we'll pile up all the possible things
that the
value can be red green blue and yellow
red green blue and yellow red
green blue and yellow and we start up
constraint propagation
so we say for the upper left hand corner
state
is there any reason to believe that r is
impossible
well we look at our neighbors and see
what kind of constraint flows in from
them
and sure this guy could be green and
this guy can be blue
they don't have to be red so there's no
nothing that rules out red and there's
nothing that rules out blue
and there's nothing that rolls out
yellow and there's nothing
rolls out green so constraint
propagation just sits there
with its finger up its nose doing
nothing
so it doesn't look like we can use
either
depth first search
or constraint propagation so we could
just
give up and cry but maybe there's some
other approach that will help
so let me actually work the texas
problem
so with apologies to houston
and tyler here's the map of texas
there we are and here's uh roughly
speaking arizona
is over here somewhere and we've got
oklahoma in there
and uh old bill clinton's state arkansas
and then louisiana sticks out there a
little bit
so there's our map of
that particular part of the country so
we've got arizona here
oklahoma here arkansas here
and louisiana here and texas here
and we have elected to assign colors to
these states
in that order so this is one two
three four
and we're going to do that and we're
going to rotate our color choices just
so we don't overuse any one color
but we're going to also have a look at
texas as we go around because texas is a
state that borders on the
states that we're choosing colors for
so the only possible colors that texas
could be are red
green blue and yellow
so as we make our choices around here
we'll say that
i don't know we don't have to adhere to
any particular style we can say that
arizona is going to get colored red
our that's going to rule out our over
here for texas
because no adjacent states can have the
same color
then we go over to oklahoma and we're
rotating our color choices so we'll say
that can be green
and that's fine because it's consistent
with the red here but it rules out the
possibility that texas can be green
and then we go over here to arkansas red
green
blue that's fine that's consistent with
the green on oklahoma
but if we look at its neighbors we know
that texas is
forever forbidden to be blue now
so now we go over to louisiana and
remember we're rotating our color
choices because we don't
want to overuse them so this means that
the first choice we're going to make
here for louisiana
is yellow
and that's fine because it's consistent
with arkansas but it's not so fine
because it's now ruled out the last
possibility
for texas so even though texas is going
to be the 50th
48th 48th state that we color
we're going to say at this point there's
no need in going on
we'd better back up because there's
nothing left for texas when we get
around to coloring it
so that means that this yellow is ruled
out here
this yellow reappears we select the next
color in line for louisiana which
happens to be red
and now that's consistent with this
yellow that's still left for texas and
it's also consistent with the blue
that's up here for arkansas
so that's cool i wonder if we maybe we
can make an algorithm out of that
and solve problems like this we see sort
of the intuition of what we're doing
we're actually using the martial arts
principle again because the whole
problem
is that local constraints undiscovered
local constraints are causing downstream
problems
so we're going to use the enemy's powers
against them and we're going to look at
those local constraints as we go
and make sure they're not going to get
us downstream not going to get us later
on
so now i'm going to i'm going to get i'm
going to look like i'm getting a little
formal
but i'm just getting a little bit more
formal because i want to have a language
have some language that i can use to
describe what's going on so it's clear
what the choices are
so to start off with we're going to have
to have some vocabulary
so let's start up our vocabulary here
we're going to have a notion of a
variable
v and that's something that can have an
assignment
yeah just you know
yeah there's nothing complicated about
that and a value
a value x is something that can
be an assignment
a little bit circular but we're all
computer scientists you know what i mean
so the next thing is a little slightly
less
obvious and that's a notion of a domain
d and that's going to be a bag
of values
okay so one more thing a constraint
that's a constraint c is a
limit on
well in our examples it's mostly going
to be pairs of variables
pairs of variable values but in general
it could be variable values
so if we go back here to texas we can
say okay
how does that vocabulary drape itself
over that configuration
and the answer is the states have the
role
of variables the colors have the role
of values
and the domains are the remaining color
possibilities
that we can still use on a particular
state and the constraint in this case is
the simple map coloring constraint that
no
states that share a boundary can have
the same color
so states are variables colors are
values
domains are bags of colors and
constraints
there's only one json states can't have
the same
color so that's how it fits with this
vocabulary
so now what did i actually do here well
what i actually did here i'm going to
now
formalize a little bit by writing it
down in a in pseudocode
so here we are we're going to have a
look at what we did here intuit with our
intuition
and we're going to reduce it to a
procedure and here's the procedure
remember we're doing depth first search
on this stuff i did a depth first search
we're going to do a depth first search
and for each
depth first search
assignment
okay so here i am i'm labeling arizona
and then oklahoma and arkansas and then
louisiana
when i lay when i give each one of those
a label a color
i'm gonna i'm gonna do this procedure
every time i make one of those
assignments the last one was
the last one that caused trouble was
coloring louisiana yellow each time i
put one of those colors down each time i
make an assignment i'm going to do this
procedure so for each step first
assignment for each
variable
v considered
now i don't know what i mean by you
don't know what i mean by considered but
when i
put a label when i put a value i
chose something as a color for louisiana
i thought about texas so i was
considering the variable texas
when i made the assignment for louisiana
i'm going to be a little bit vague about
what i mean by considered right now
because there are lots of choices about
how much stuff you actually consider
so let me just say consider and then
we'll open that up and talk about the
options in a moment
so for each variable v considered
for let's call that variable
v sub i for each
x sum i for each value in
the domain of that variable
i'm going to consider each of the things
that's still surviving
for each of those for
each constraint
c that's between x sub i
and some x sub j
where
x sub j is an element of the domain
of j oh that sounds awfully fancy but
that just says
in the case of texas up there whenever i
consider one of the values that's
still remaining as a choice for texas i
want to consider
all of the constraints between that
variable and and the adjacent value and
the adjacent states
and i want to be sure that anything i
leave in the domain
is okay for some selection in the other
states
some remaining choices in the other
states so that's why
we're getting pretty nested here but
we're doing depth first search
we are considering the variables in a
certain collection
of a certain collection of variables
for each one of those we're considering
all the values that still remain
in the domains of those variables and
then for each of those values we're
checking to see if it satisfies that
some constraint
satisfies the constraint that are placed
upon it
so for each of these constraints
if there does not exist
an x sub j such that
the constraint between x sub i and x sub
j
is satisfied
well if in that adjacent place there's
no nothing that is consistent with
a value then we've got to get rid of it
if it if that's true if there does not
exist some
some value in an adjacent variable such
that that constraint is satisfied we
we're hosed we got to get we got to get
rid of that value so we're going to
remove
x sub i from
d sub i
okay now that that's fine that's sort of
what i did with texas i
as soon as i plopped down a value for
louisiana
i said well what are what are the
possible values in texas red green blue
and yellow
let's consider red let's consider the
constraints between texas and all the
adjacent states
one of those constraints says it can't
be the same color as arizona
the only color i've got available for
arizona since i've already made the
assignment is red
red is not consistent with red so i've
got to get rid of it
so it looks complicated but it's just
intuition
so what do we do if we get to a
situation where the domain is empty
that means whenever we get around to
making an assignment to it there won't
be anything left
so if that ever happens if
the domain ever becomes empty
then what do we do we got to back up
all right so the intuition is clear this
is the algorithm
the algorithm when you work through it
think about whether it makes sense and
whatnot how it fits with texas yeah it
sure does all we're doing
is we're making these depth first
assignments and in the neighborhood of
those depth first assignments
we're looking around to see if the
values that are possible
include something and if they don't
include anything we know we made
an irrevocable blunder and we have to
back up
so that's the essence of the idea
now how well does it work well it
depends on
a little bit depends on what we choose
for
considered there are lots of choices for
what we consider
so let me enumerate some of those
choices and then we'll work it out on uh
we'll have a look and see what they do
oh i i guess one possibility to consider
nothing
let's try it out
so our type of search is going to be no
checks
what do you think is going to happen
we're not even checking the assignment
well that's pretty fast unfortunately
since we haven't even checked the most
recent assignment we get lots of places
where they're
states that are adjacent to each other
that have the same color
that's no good
so another thing we can do is
consider every everything
that's no good because that would say as
soon as we color our first state
we check to make sure that every other
you know all 47 other states can be
colored
that seems like overdoing it a little
bit
but in any case at least we want to
check
the assignment
so if we go back here and check the
assignment
let's see what happens
assignments only boom all that geez
that's
that's what i got in trouble before this
is the thing that's going to run
for uh
17 billion years at nanosecond you know
something like that
well it's only a billion years if you
run it at nanosecond speed so i guess
maybe you could
do that have a fast computer but this
isn't going to work because of our
unfortunate choice of texas as the
as the last state to be considered
and the unfortunate coloring of the four
surrounding states right up front
and our unfortunate decision to rotate
the colors so as to avoid
overdoing any one color
so this doesn't work but you know we
went to the trouble of working out
the the business with um with texas
by hand using the domain reduction
algorithm
better make a note that this is the
domain reduction algorithm
and what we're going to do is we're
going to check the neighbors of the
assignments
just like we did here we checked texas
each time we made one of those four
choices
because it's a neighbor of all of the
choices of the states that we made
so one thing to do is check neighbors
so this is one two three now let's see
what happens
check neighbors only go
shoot i don't know it's okay with texas
right
because um it didn't color the states
around texas
uh with all four color choices
but it's still getting in trouble uh in
other places
uh like all like the states like
missouri kentucky
virginia tennessee states with lots of
lots of
boundaries so i don't know
whether this is gonna oh there it
finally worked
phew did a lot of went through a lot of
effort though
i know for the sake of comparison we
might make a note that it ran into
9139 dead ends
so um but uh it did do some good it
didn't take
a length of time longer than the
remaining part of the universe
but if it's a good idea to check the
neighbors
if we make a change to the neighbors
what might that suggest that we do in
addition
well it might suggest that if we make a
change to a neighbor that we
check its neighbors too make sure
they're all right
so a another choice
is to propagate
so propagate through variables with
reduced
domains let's see how that works
well wait a minute um
i must have made a mistake let's try
that again
oh maybe we better slow it down
all that gray stuff is showing the limit
of the of the propagation
man it's um see it for a second
of 40 that's about 10 seconds
boom not bad zero dead ends
and it was a lot faster i didn't happen
to notice how many constraints were
checked
another thing i think was around twenty
thousand or so this is a lot less
so this looks like a good idea but why
do they
why do they label it number five well
because there's something between this
and number three
so number four is
through v with d
reduced
to one value
so we're not going to propagate through
all of the variables who have that which
have their domains
shrunk a little bit we're only going to
propagate through those that have the
greater shrinkage all the way down to a
single value
all right so let's see how that might
work
anybody want to place any bets on this
one
let's see we checked 2623 constraints
last time
let's see what happens this time
you you can see that the extent of the
gray is less because it's not
propagating so far
and as we breathfully await the answer
we see we found our winner this is does
a couple of dead ends but the number of
constraints checked is less than a
thousand
so in general with problems like this
you have all of these choices for what
you consider
you don't want to consider nothing
because then you're not honoring your
constraints
you'll certainly want to consider the
things you've just made assignments for
because otherwise you'll
pre-date giving you'll construct a
solution that
violates a constraint you do want don't
want to do
everything because that's excessive work
and so these two i'm sorry
checking the neighbors is a good idea
but it's always better in practice
in practice inevitably it's the case
that it's better to do some propagation
through the things that you've changed
how much propagation it doesn't seem to
do much good to propagate through things
that are just changed
but it does seem to do some good to
propagate through things that have
changed and been reduced to a single
value
so as soon as you've got a neighbor of
some assignment you just made
that has its domain reduced to a single
value then you check its neighbors too
so you check the neighbors of the
neighbors of the neighbors of the
neighbors
on and on and on as long as you've found
a domain being reduced and not only
being reduced but reduced to a single
value
all right so that's the domain reduction
algorithm and i guarantee we're going to
give you a problem like that
and i know you don't know how to work
those problems yet
because this is a little bit abstract
and to work these
problems in the exam setting you need to
know a little bit
about how to keep track of the variable
values and remain in the domains
and that sort of thing and and you'll
learn more about that in your
recitations and in this mega recitation
and
tutorials so we could go home
except that there are few little
flourishes to deal with here
and those flourishes
those flourishes include some
dirty filthy little secrets
for example i've chosen as my classroom
example
to pick on texas and arrange for this
situation to be
especially ugly so i i could
arrange the states in a different way uh
we have highly constrained states we
have a lot of bordering states around
them
and we have other states like maine
up there that has only one as only
borders on one other state
so i don't know will
what do you think should we um
should we arrange the states in for our
depth first search
in the order of least constrained to
most constrained or most constrained to
lease constraint
in other words should we start with
missouri or tennessee or
kentucky or something like that or
should we start with maine
what do you think you have a 50 chance
of getting it right just by
flipping a coin
he thinks we should start with the most
constraint first
do we have a volunteer who wants to
suggest that we start with the lease
constraint first
that's the way i always uh that's the
way i always work on stuff i
you know i'm working on a book or
something i have 500 things to fix i'll
always choose to work on the easiest
stuff first so that i feel like i'm
making the list a lot smaller
leave the hardest things to last but we
don't have any volunteers do you want to
want to bet on on that idea least
constraint first
okay jason wants to suggest that we
should
work on the least constraint first well
we have ground truth because we can just
try it out
i guess we'll stick with our shrinking
to one value thing here
but we will reorder things so that we
have the
least constrained first
so that we right away we got a color for
uh for maine
maybe we ought to speed this up a little
bit
okay well that's a good idea uh jason
suggested this and
we only checked 1732 constraints and we
had 59 dead ends so let's try the other
way around
and we'll go back to four frames a
second
so we're working kind of from the middle
of the country out with this one
we're going to deal with maine i guess
last
yeah which is better
too bad i think it looks like this is
better
in fact let's not be so aggressive with
the use of constraint propagation
let's just check the assignments only if
we go back to
an arrangement where we have least
constrain first
and we'll crank up the speed
well actually we'd have to crank it up
pretty big because uh
the st states like missouri tennessee
kentucky they're gonna they're gonna be
like texas
and so we're kind of back to the length
of the universe type problem here with
the least constrained first and
no constrain and no use of constraints
other than to check the
the current assignment
so let's uh stop that though and
check the most constrained first
assignments only
i don't know how long was this going to
take
that's the dirty little secret if we had
arranged our states
from most constraint to least
constrained ordinary depth first search
with none of this stuff we talked about
today would work just fine
all right
so uh it's a little bit like uh like
games do you use progressive deepening
or do you use alpha beta and the answer
is both
you use everything you got to uh to to
to deal with
with the problems and depending on the
problem
one or another of the things you
incorporate into your approach will work
just great
if you're lucky so now
i promise that this is not useful not
only for people who want to color maps
god who wants to do that we know it can
be done with four colors but it's also
useful for doing all kinds of resource
planning
problems so when i want to show you a
resource planning problem and i want you
to think about while i'm doing it
think about whether it's actually
analogous to the map coloring problem
all right
so here's the deal you have just landed
a summer job
with jet green a new airline
and jet green is a is a
low-cost no frills
hardly any maintenance type of airline
and they want to fly mostly between
boston and new york
occasionally they want to fly to los
angeles and they're trying to get by
with the smallest number of airplanes
so that's why we have a kind of resource
allocation problem
jet green so i'm going to write down
what their schedule looks like they have
one flight
f1 that goes from boston
to uh los angeles to uh jfk
like so it's a early in the day flight
then they want to have another one f2
that flies from
jfk to boston
and then they want to have another
flight a little later in the day
that flies from boston to jfk
and a little later than that they want
to have another flight that goes from
jfk to boston
they're going to start off mostly as a
shuttle airline in the beginning so
that's
f1 f2 f3
and f4 and they have a fifth flight
f5 that goes from boston to los angeles
that takes a long time
so it looks uh like this on on the
schedule of course we have time going
that way
so that's boston to
lax
now your job is to determine if they can
fly this schedule with four aircraft
and naturally you don't want to overuse
any one aircraft because you like to
have
kind of even even wear on them right so
as you make your choices
you'll rotate the aircraft so you'll
assign
this one to a1 aircraft number one
this one will be a2 this one will be a3
and this one will be a4 and
oops uh there's no aircraft left for the
flight to los angeles
because i have four so it's obvious
right this is
100 exactly the map coloring problem
even down to the four choices because
you have the constraint the no single
physical aircraft
can fly on fly two flights at the same
time just like no two adjacent states
can be colored the same
so there's a no same no same time
constraint like so
so if you were assigning flight aircraft
to these flights
you get down to f4 the fourth flight
and you'd say well let's see
this guy down here can be a1 a2 a3 or a4
but if i choose
a4 for that fourth flight then there'll
be nothing left in its domain
so you've thus
set the problem up to be identical to
the map coloring problem and of course
you you can enrich it with other kinds
of constraints
so for example you might have this is a
not same time constraint
and these
i mean this is at jfk and it flies out
of jfk so
maybe you can use those maybe use the
same aircraft for those
but not if they're right up against each
other because you have a minimum ground
time rule
so there's a minimum ground time
constraint here
and there's a minimum ground time
constraint here
there's a minimum ground time constraint
here
and if these aren't the same city then
you've got to allow enough time for them
to fly between the two cities that are
involved
so the constraints can get a little bit
more complicated but the idea is the
same
so you say to me i don't trust you show
me
okay so let me show you
oh by the way there's one more way to
make this map coloring problem easier
right
let's see the arrangement is going to be
alphabetical
the type is going to be assignments only
and we know that's a loser but not if we
use a whole lot of colors
so it's the use of four colors that got
us into trouble
oh that's an aside but it will be coming
back in a moment or two
scheduling here's that problem
boom yep you can almost see it working
just like a map coloring thing
but that's maybe too easy
let's do this one
see this is just like uh this is like
simplicia we we've
kind of got a a goofy arrangement here
that's guaranteed
to lose at the bottom because of choices
made at the top
but that's okay we can we can stop this
and we can do we can change to
check neighbors only and boom there it
goes
all right or alternatively let me see if
i can do it this way most constrained
first
type will be assignments only boom
that worked fine too
so you might choose to have a slightly
harder problem
i don't know like this and we can
search away
actually i don't know if this will
complete or not this is a randomly
generated example
but deal you know you're going to lose
your summer job if you can't figure out
whether you can do this or not
so what are you going to do
elliot you got your thoughts about how
you're going to save your job
so here's the question you've been asked
how many
airplanes does jet green need
and you decide well four seemed to work
before
so we'll try four here and you're not
sure if it's going to terminate or not
i mean in your in your in your lifetime
let alone in your summer job
elliot let me give you a hint look at
the outline
the outline up here on the board the
last item
now what's that mean
how many what's the maximum number of
airplanes we're going to need
suppose we've got five flights
what's the maximum number of airplanes
would ever need five
what's the minimum number of airplanes
we'll need one
so let's try let's try it with a small
number of airplanes and a large number
of airplanes
so that showed us very fast that we
can't do it with one airplane
that showed us very fast we could do it
with 10 airplanes
what are we going to do to find the
actual number as fast as possible
and at least give our boss a reasonable
answer
even if not necessarily the exact number
very fast
it's just it's easy right we're gonna
start up here with one computer
and we're gonna start down here with
another computer
and see what happens so let's see
if we can do it with nine
let's see if we can do it with eight
let's see if we can do it with seven
these take almost zero time right
because they're under constrained
now that's good seven let's try six
actually let's try two
it loses fast let's try three
don't know maybe if you let it run long
enough three will work
i doubt it while we're at it though we
might as well
go back here and try it with six
remember seven worked real fast
oh she's six so that was six right yeah
so let's try it with five
okay so it runs real fast with five it
terminates real quick with
two so we've got three and four left
so we can tell our boss a la anytime
algorithm
that you're not real sure but you know
it's going to be either three or four
and then you got two computers you can
let both run and see if either one
terminate
so you three and four my guess is that
three
will eventually give up but of course uh
there's another little problem here we
haven't used the most constraint first
if we did that we might be able to do it
even faster actually i don't think i can
make that switch without getting another
random assignment but
let's see what happens maybe so
i already had most constraint first okay
so it didn't it didn't help to actually
switch and i got it i got to think i've
got a new schedule to work here
so that's the that's the that's the end
of the story you can do
good resource allocation if you do
several things all at once
number one you always want to use most
constraints first number two you want to
propagate through domains reduced to a
single algorithm
and number three if you're really trying
to figure out what the minimum number of
resources needed is you do this under
over
business and you can quickly converge on
a narrow range where the search is
taking a long time and be sure that it
lies within that
narrow range because when you over
source it's fast and when
fast to complete and when you under
resource it's
fast to terminate and so you can just
squeeze it right down into a very small
range
and that is the end of the story enjoy
your holiday on monday
we'll have two classes next week on
wednesday
and friday as advertised
you